good morning believe nation today's
message is be a part of something that's
appreciated over to you Paul Walker
awake mode press the TV go I enjoy doing
them but more than that actually let me
rephrase that I think the reason why I
enjoy it so much is because how much the
people get off the audience appreciates
what we do you know there's a lot of
things I could be doing outside of the
industry even within the industry but
you know I don't know if the
satisfaction would be the same you know
because to be a part of something that
people really appreciate as much as
maybe certain people hate to admit it
and it's important to us you know it's
humans it's like you want to believe
that you know what you're putting out
there and what you've dedicated so much
time to is it there's a certain degree
of acknowledgment and more than
acknowledgement and appreciation you
know obviously this one's been
appreciated for a long time and that's
it that's a great feeling I think as
entrepreneurs is important not just to
be a part of something that's
appreciated but to create something that
is appreciated I think as entrepreneurs
we have that ability that a lot of
people don't have if you're if you're in
a job or working in a career working for
somebody else you have the chance i
guess to try to pick somebody that you
could work with but otherwise you're at
this you're at the subject of their
decision making in the project that they
want to work on whereas an entrepreneur
we get to create whatever you want to
create and if you can create something
that is appreciated both by you and your
customers and your team that's the
homerun I think about my youtube channel
I make a lot of these videos selfishly
for me because I want them to exist I
want them to be here and I share with
you guys and I'm so honored that you
guys enjoy them and love them and watch
them and comment on them and I keep
putting out that same schedule and I
keep creating more and I keep making
them public instead of just something
for me
because of the appreciation because I
feel good doing it because every time I
post a video I know I get tons of
comments down below from you guys either
saying that give you a boost for the day
give you a great idea in some cases
change your lives help you make
important decisions and that makes me
feel good and I share that with my team
and that makes them feel good too and I
think it's something that isn't talked
about a lot in business we tend to talk
about making enough money and profits
and how much you're going to sell your
product for and marketing strategies and
the the practical hands-on stuff but I
think creating something that is
appreciated is really important because
it helps one give a sense of meaning and
purpose to what you're doing and also
helps get you through the hard times
right when when I was struggling and
suffering and not making any money in my
business the thing that got me through
was knowing that what I made was having
a positive impact on people's lives you
know it may not be a lot of people that
I want him to feel a lot more people but
I was having a positive and significant
impact on a few people's lives and
knowing that that was appreciated help
me make two wanna keep going on the flip
side to that I would also say show
appreciation to the people and
businesses that are adding value to your
life one of the things that I try to do
as an example since I value and
appreciate my youtube comments so much
when I watch videos on somebody else's
channel I always try to leave a comment
to show my appreciation for what they're
doing especially the smaller channels
because i remember when i was getting
one comment per video like 0 comments /
bidding you're like oh I got a comment I
got a reply or 3 comments or 10 comments
we still make an effort to reply to
every single comment if it's if it's me
or Nina or now Ivan who's on my team
helping respond to every single comment
because I feel that's the right thing to
do but I would encourage you to if you
are liking somebody else's stuff you buy
their product you buy their service you
watch the YouTube video whatever it is
show your appreciation because you know
how much that means to you go and give
it to others
Wow belief so question the day I'd love
to know from you an example of
appreciation that's really meant
something to you whether it was a
feedback from a video or customer or
someone just saying thank you something
I really touched you or how you make a
conscious effort to appreciate others
what do you do that maybe I could learn
from and others could learn from as well
leave it in the comments down below
really curious to find out thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press oh I wish this brace okie
me go